[Musique]
professeur raoul bonjour bonjour on vous
attend
je suis désolé je lui ai dit oui sans
vérifier hier soir parce qu'on m'a
frappé dans le couloir et sa femme qu'à
l'est pas avec la suite mon programme je
fais toutes mes excuses donc vous ne
venez pas en fait non non je ne viens
pas à payer parce
qu'elle est l'homme du jour à présent et
bien c'est ministre des transports jean
baptiste du baril qui est très populaire
chez les jeunes justement c'est la star
du réseau social tik tok alors la
plupart des personnalités politiques
vous savez c'est d'être présent ce
réseau social des jeunes avec plus ou
moins de succès d'ailleurs mais lui
visiblement il a tous les codes ils
allaient bon filtre vous le voyez la
lettre c'est un masque de race un filtre
de tête de rat j'ai appelé ça oui c'est
lui qui a rajouté ça sur sa vidéo
exactement
[Musique]
ces chiffres s'ils regardent ya une news
pour vous mais sienne comme en fait
cette vidéo qui promeut le train de nuit
qui permet d'économiser dit-il de nuit
airbnb il a les codes il a le
vocabulaire il a les références des
jeunes 3 millions de vues en moins de 24
heures pour cette vidéo est énormément
de commentaires élogieux on a le
meilleur ministre dés transports donnez
lui les clés de l'église et à vie voilà
ce que pensent les japonais dans tous
les autres pays vont faire ça ils vont
se mettre d euros mais lui et a le truc
je repasse mon équipe ont ils vont
calais ça avec vous et vous venez nous
rejoindre honnêtement c'est vraiment des
choses que vous pouvez faire professeurs
mais nous les couacs le prêt d'un taxi
vous en voyez on va vous envoyer un taxi
pour que vous nous rejoignez vous
arrivez vous arrivez quand vous arrivez
dans l'émission on est on est à
l'antenne jusqu'à midi donc vous vous
nous rejoignez d'accord
ces affaires
merci les professeurs font ne savent pas
vous dépêcher
mais je sais pas s'il peut maintenir
voici le nouveau jeu délirant délire aux
toilettes ou sera-t-il et sa tête aux
pieds des toilettes les yeux rendait
d'une folle vider les crottes attention
que tu mets les pieds le joueur avec le
plus de 30 sur la tête dès l'ouverture
le lac a carrément génial ça pue
tat dégueulasse des duvets quad
mais t'es sérieux
[Musique]
c'est arrivé alors heureusement que t'as
pas fait ça j'ai cru que c'était à
mettet des lunettes mais j'ai cru que
c'était le lait le canadian à genève en
scène la pâte à tartiner à l'apa n'a pas
dépassé les limites a été gentil avec
moi mais au début j en direct avec tous
sur ce plateau le professeur out bonjour
professeurs merci d'être là on a eu
chaud aux belles choses depuis locaux
vides je vis de ma musique
j'ai écrit une chanson pour michael
jackson parce que voilà
j'en ai deux à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
pour lui payer mort jousselme et moi
j'arrive un peu
je suis entre la terre et le ciel
les visiteurs avance sur une sorte
d'observatoire tout en transparence un
jeu de miroirs donne l'impression de
marcher sur le ciel quand les plaques de
verre elle propulse dans le vide les
repères sont bouleversés les perception
faussée de conseils avant d'y aller
sujet au vertige s'abstenir et éviter
les jupes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attendre
bienvenue à issoire la ville où il ne
pleut jamais enfin presque oui c'est
vrai il fait toujours chance quand tu
fais des averses cherchent le soleil
cherche un styliste cherche un prof de
chant
et quand même vous installez s'il vous
plaît parce que 0-0 et qatar c'est une
cata on n'a jamais vu ça jamais
que tes côtés je suis la troisième
meilleure de maïs rien du tout
donc si vous aussi vous êtes nuls venez
jouer si vous aussi vous ne connaissez
aucune chanson si vous ne savez rien de
rien profitez-en c'est le moment
apparemment et des journées portes
ouvertes aux sélections points positifs
seront encore dans ce costume
point négatif
tu rentres encore dans ce costume
festival de la guerre commence
[Musique]
elodie et déguisés comme une vraie
dunkerquois c'est pas très beau à voir
j'ai l'impression d'avoir un croisement
d'un gilet jaune avec un animal tout
simplement tout à l'heure quand vous
êtes venu là pour trouver l'âme soeur
vous avez oublié l'essentiel vous êtes
un spécialiste des moules et moules
déboule à des boules à wil alors oui
tout à fait oui c'est
cool c'est parce que je voulais dire
vous m'avez pas entendu c'est les boules
et regarde pas les moules parler boulot
aussi paraître dans les corps comment il
fait pour draguer
c'est vrai cette fois ci c'est vrai
ça vous fait bon c'est pas de règle
non sincèrement
ils ont travaillé ensemble
il est drôle il est drôle elle aussi
j'ai le sens à l'heure où troubles
nagui restez à votre place
on va passer de ma vie à me dire ça qui
aurait pu penser pour ceux qui suivent
votre parcours il ya 20 ou 30 ans que
vous seriez en tête de gondole pour tf1
déjà par mois et j'imagine voilà mais ça
veut dire quoi en fait
bah ça veut dire que
ça veut aussi dire que je me suis fait
happer par le système des choses comme
ça la pause et
vous êtes un support que
vous méritez bien les avocats votre
votre nos de baveux vous n'arrêtez pas
ça n'arrête pas le dernier mot le
dernier vous êtes un baveux c'est la
pause à tout de suite c'est beau on
peut-être aussi le système un peu changé
c'est à dire que le système aussi des
stars il faut qu'il soit aussi j'ai joué
avec moi composantes aussi quoi le
système à mon avis il ya aussi kouaoua
pour pour parfumer du pingouin il est
obligé quoi tu vois quoi l'île de la
palma aux canaries a dépassé le cap du
mois des rup sion volcaniques plus de 30
jours de lave de cendres d'explosion du
combes et vieira les coulées de lave ont
détruit près de 2000 bâtiments et
recouvert 7 162 hectares de leur masse
visqueuse c'est l'équivalent de 1000
terrain de football l'une d'entre elles
a même créé un delta de lave dans
l'océan c'est la saison des volcans qui
semble tour à tour se réveiller cette
fois c'est le noise aux plus grands
volcans du japon qui est entré en
éruption ce matin événement
spectaculaire sur ces images que vous
voyez là en accéléré des cendres
volcaniques se sont élevées à 3500
mètres au dessus du cratère avant de
tout envahir sur leur passage